So,
hi,
welcome back to human emotion.
So as we spoke about in our last lecture about emotion regulation,
we've seen that some people seem to have full regulatory control over their
emotions as you can see on the left,
whereas others seem to have literally almost no control over their emotions
whatsoever.
Um,
and the question that we've been trying to ask is precisely how and when are
people able to really take these reigns over their emotions and what does it
mean to do this?
So today we're going to follow up and our second module and emotion regulation
by turning to what is the empirical evidence behind emotion regulation to date.
So what does the scientific data actually say about whether or not we can indeed
control our feelings?
So what we're gonna do today with our roadmap is first cover the evidence on
emotion regulation followed by takeaway questions and an expert interview.
So I want to briefly refresh ourselves from last lecture on what the definition
of emotion regulation was.
So again,
as defined by James Gross,
he said that emotion regulation encompasses the processes by which individuals
influence which emotions they have,
when they have them,
and how they experience and express their emotions.
And again,
this is the process model of emotion regulation that we covered in the last
lecture,
which really goes through a series of strategies and rough temporal sequence
that suggests when and how people manage their emotions with particular
attention given to strategies such as situation modification or selection,
attentional deployment,
cognitive reappraisal and suppression.
And again,
this is a recursive model.
So any one type of emotion response here can then generate an entirely new type
of emotional experience,
which then itself would be subsequently regulated.
So it's important when we talk about emotion regulation as we move forward to
differentiated among three related overlapping but distinct concepts constructs.
So the first,
when we think about emotion regulation is to differentiate it from what's called
coping.
So coping is distinguished from emotion regulation in so far as coping,
mostly focuses on decreasing negative emotion and covers a much longer time
periods such as coping with bereavement after the death of a loved one.
Emotion regulation is also distinct from mood regulation.
So as we discussed earlier in our course,
moods and emotions are distinct.
Moods are typically have a longer duration and don't often have behavioral or
behavioral or physiological signatures.
So hence mood regulation focuses on a longer term state and more specifically
the experiential or subjective component of emotion.
Whereas emotion regulation covers also behavioral and physiological response
domains.
Finally,
emotion regulation is distinct from what are called psychological defenses that
originated.
It originated in the Floridian literature and usually focused on the regulation
of aggressive or sexual impulses solely or as emotion regulation goes much
broader than simply these impulses and defenses are also usually unconscious.
Whereas emotion regulation can also be actively conscious as well.
So what I want to do now is think about what is the evidence to date on distinct
kinds of what we call emotion regulation.
Strategies are different,
uh,
tactics by which we can flexibly maneuver our emotions,
either up or down and either more positive or more negative.
So one commonly used strategy that's gained a lot of scientific data has been
called cognitive reappraisal and cognitive reappraisal that we saw on our
process model was defined as construing an emotion eliciting situation in a way
that alters its emotional impact.
And indeed,
this is a form of cognitive change that's been common to many existing cognitive
behavioral or CBT interventions for disorders ranging from depression to anxiety
to bipolar disorder.
And we've seen empirical evidence from James Gross and colleagues suggest that
cognitive reappraisal is actually associated with reductions in both negative
emotion and reductions and physiological arousal,
which has led it to be really esteemed as one of the most putatively adaptive
emotion regulation strategies studied to date.
So this is cognitive reappraisal.
Um,
I want to show you what this looks like in the context of an experimental study.
So participants who come into the lab,
we'll often be asked to watch emotion,
eliciting film clips.
And here's the kinds of instructions they will receive when trying to
cognitively reappraise.
The response.
So this is from James Grossest studies where participants come in and read the
following instructions.
So you'll be viewing a short film clip.
Please try to adopt a detached and unemotional attitude as you watch the film.
In other words,
as you watch the film,
try to think about what you are seeing objectively in terms of the technical
aspects of the events you observe.
Watch the film clip carefully,
but please try to think about what you are seeing so you don't feel anything at
all.
And so the second strategy would be behavioral suppression.
So this is a strategy that's been defined as attempting to suppress or inhibit
outward displays of emotion,
as we spoke about earlier.
And it's also something that is less common in a existing CBT interventions.
And it's actually by contrast associated with increased physiological responses.
So this is behavioral suppression.
So again,
an experimental studies when you try to experiments,
he manipulates suppression.
The instructions would be as follows.
Again,
this is borrowing from James grosses experimental paradigms.
So it would be different from reappraisal.
And so far as the instructions would read,
you'll be viewing a short film clip if you have any feelings as you watch the
film clip,
please try your best not to let those feelings show.
In other words,
as you watch the film clip tried to behave in such a way that a person watching
you would not know you were feeling anything.
So watch the film clip carefully,
but please try to behave so that someone watching you would not know that you
were feeling anything at all.
Okay.
And finally,
these are often contrasted both reappraisal and suppression with the control
condition,
which is simply called watch.
So participants would simply be asked to view a short film film clip and watch
the film clip carefully.
So this would look something as follows,
if we were doing experimental study on reappraisal and suppression as compared
to a control condition.
So participants would come into a lab and acclimate as part of a resting
baseline.
Subsequently,
they would be asked to simply engage in what watching an emotional film.
And they could either watch the film and let their emotions naturally arise.
Cogley tried to reappraise the film by adopting a detached and unemotional
attitude or suppress.
So try to,
it behaviourally inhibit the responses and so that no one could see what their
outward expressive displays where this would be followed by watching either a
positive film clip,
a negative film clip,
or a neutral film clip.
And subsequently you would measure emotional responding across subjective effect
of components,
behavioral displays,
and physiological responses.
Okay.
So what are the consequences of engaging in different kinds of emotion
regulation strategies such as those that we talked about today?
Primarily suppression reappraisal as compared to a control condition where
people simply that their emotions arise as they would.
So the short term consequences that have arisen out of laboratory studies
conducted by both James Gross and his colleague Bob Levenson looked something
like this.
So they found that when it came to subjective experience,
when people try to behave really suppress their emotions,
what you found is that suppression either decreased emotion or had no effect at
all,
and reappraisal decreased both positive and negative emotion intensity.
So reappraisal seem to be most powerful,
decreasing emotion intensity across the board.
Whereas suppression seem to decrease positive but had no change on negative
emotion when it came to outward displays of behavior.
Not Surprising the suppression,
the instructions inherently asks you to inhibit your outward displays,
the behavior.
So we see that suppression is associated with reductions in behavioral displays
of emotion,
whereas reappraisal is also associated with reductions in behavioral displays of
emotion.
And again,
these are in contrast with the watch condition.
So look compared to people's naturally unfolding emotion responses.
Now this bottom thing at the bottom row here and yellow physiology is one that I
find the most interesting.
So while suppression actually does lead you to inhibit your displays of emotion
and shows maybe some reduction in emotion intensity,
what you see here with the plus sign indicates is that it's amplifying your
physiological responding.
So it's almost as if the more you try to inhibit the emotions you're showing in
your face,
the more they're sort of this,
um,
downstream almost.
Um,
I think of it as like a sort of bounce back effect where your autonomic system
just ratchets up.
So in a way suppression seems to be not wholly effective.
We're trying to not show what we're feeling but our,
but our bodies amping up physiologically heart rate,
skin conductance,
sort of the autonomic nervous system is counteracting that in response.
Whereas what you see with re reappraisal and why it's gained so much attention
as a potentially punitive adaptive strategy is that it really seems to decrease
emotion intensity across the board.
So you see decreased motion experience behavior and physiological activation.
So this is a short term consequences.
This is in the context of the well defined experimental laboratory paradigm that
we walked through.
What about longterm consequences?
What about people who tend to use these strategies such as suppression or
reappraisal in everyday life?
What do they look like?
So this is some work that,
um,
well we'll go ratan that in a second actually.
So when we think about the longterm consequences,
so this is work done by James Gross and other colleagues such as all of our
John,
uh,
among others is what we see.
And this is really interesting.
So people who tend to self report engaging in cognitive reappraisal on an
everyday basis have a wide variety of really adaptive longterm consequences.
So they have better social relationships,
they cope better with stress and they report more positive emotion.
Whereas those who engage in a more frequent basis and behavioral suppression
report feeling less authentic and social life,
they have poor coping strategies when trying to manage stress and they actually
tend to report less positive and more negative emotion.
So it seems that when we try to engage in behavioral suppression in Everyday
Thought,
it seems that we really,
um,
diminish our internal cognitive resources.
We're not coping with stress as much and we're actually feeling like we're
leaving an inauthentic life.
That's also manifest in terms of feeling less positive and more negative.
Again,
it seems to be that in the long run,
cognitive reappraisal seems to be one of the most adaptive strategies,
at least compared to suppression.
So what about findings,
looking at emotion regulation in the brain?
So to what extent does the data suggests that we can actually regulate our
emotions in ways that show distinct patterns of neural activity?
So this is work that's really been pioneered by Kevin Ochsner at Columbia
University and his tasks looked as follows.
So participants would view a stimulus or image like the one you see here and
they would be asked to attend to their feelings by either trying to increase
their negative feelings or decreased their negative feelings.
So when we think about using reappraisal to increase negative emotions,
they would be told to think about the image in a way that makes you feel more
negative.
So an example when looking at this image might be to think she's in pain is week
of the heart may die soon.
The other condition is to use reappraisals to try to decrease negative emotion
intensity.
So to think about the image in a way that makes you feel less negative.
So you could also cognitively construe this image to say,
well,
she's just tired or annoyed.
She,
she's hardy and will be better soon.
So what do you find in the scanner when you ask people to do this?
So in the condition where people are asked to use reappraisal to increase
negative emotion,
so again,
to sort of see the image and think either he or she is in pain,
is week of the heart may die soon.
Will you actually see,
and it's really fascinating,
you see decreased activity in the prefrontal cortex and increased activity in
the Amygdala.
So what we're seeing is decreased activity in our cognitive control centers that
are thought to be associated with successful regulatory control and increased
activity in brain regions like the Amygdala that are associated with heightened
emotion,
intensity and salience,
particularly for negative emotions.
By contrast,
and we think of reappraisal is a way to decrease negative emotion intensity.
We might think that the woman or man in the photos just tired or annoyed,
they're hardy bell be better soon.
And we see a very different pattern of finding.
So we see instead that we see heightened activation in the and sort of cognitive
control prefrontal regions such as the prefrontal cortex and decreased activity
in the Amygdala.
So what we're seeing is when we use your appraisal to decrease emotion
intensity,
we're seeing heightened activation in these cognitive control regions associated
with successful emotion regulation and decrease intensity in these more sort of
subcortical regions associated with increased emotion,
intensity and salience.
So indeed reappraisal works to both ratchet up and ratchet down activity in both
cognitive control regions and more,
um,
subcortical emotion salient regions.
So another strategy that's been looked at in addition to reappraisal and
suppression is what's been called cognitive distancing.
So this was work really sort of championed by Ethan Cross and when he talks
about cognitive dissonance saying this is defined as the repetitive focus on the
content causes and consequences of one's an affective or emotional state that is
conducive to problem solving.
And this really involves kind of what he would say,
taking a third person perspective.
So almost being a fly on the wall and taking what he would call a distance,
why perspective.
Um,
and what you find is that when people are able to sort of step back from their
emotional situation,
take a third person perspective,
that it actually shows reductions and negative emotions.
And in our lab we found that taking a third person perspective actually also
results in decreases in positive emotion intensity too.
So this cognitive distancing strategy really seems to be another effective
regulatory tool to decrease emotion intensity.
So,
um,
I'm going to show you what this looks like in the laboratory.
In some studies we've done to try to experimentally study and elicit,
um,
you know,
this cognitive regulation strategy called cognitive distancing.
So at the beginning of the experiment,
people come in and there's a resting baseline.
Afterwards we had participants in arts task think,
listen to an audio recorded script asking them to recall a happy
autobiographical experience.
And once they had identified a salient positive memory,
they were in stock,
instructed to press the space bar on the computer keypad to continue afterwards
using it within subjects design.
They were then asked to reflect on this same happy memory using either a
cognitive distancing strategies.
So trying to watch the event from a distance to adopt this third person
perspective.
Um,
or they were asked to immerse in the memory and afterwards we got reports of an
effect as well as physiological signatures of heart rate.
So let me give you an example of what this cognitive dissonance in condition
actually sounded like.
So participants again listened to a prerecorded audio script that I'll show you
right now what it looks like.
Please go back to the time in place of the same happy venue earliest at you and
see the side I emotion.
So they were taking place at the same people away from the situation earlier
applies from a,
just to take a few steps back as you do it in the situation to what is now
comment the disease.
And as they did this to focus on what has now become the distant view and as
they continue to watch the distant you to try to understand the emotions that
the distance you experienced as the event unfolded.
Why did he or she had those feelings?
What were the underlying causes and reasons.
Okay.
So what we find when we look at evidence for this distance,
why strategy,
which has also been called reflective processing as compared to a more
maladaptive strategy called rumination,
is we see the consequences to be quite divergent.
So when people are simply mauling over and emotionally that are ruminating on
it,
we see increased negative effect,
increased positive affect,
and greater physiological arousal.
So ruminating or mauling over the causes and consequences seems to sort of
amplify or ratchet up your emotion intensity.
By contrast,
when engaging in this sort of distance,
why are reflective processing by Ethan Kross and colleagues?
We see decreased negative affect,
decreased positive effect,
and decreased physiological arousal.
So by taking a third person perspective or simply stepping back,
it seems to really soothe or ease our emotion,
intensity,
whether it's positive or negative.
Now when we think about emotion regulation and think about psychopathology,
what are the ways in which emotion regulation may go awry?
And we'll talk this later in the course when we get too emotional disorders.
But what are some clues about how emotion regulation goes awry and people
suffering from mood disorders,
anxiety disorders,
schizophrenia,
and even substance abuse.
So this is something we've been working actively in our lab to try to solve this
puzzle of.
How exactly do individuals who suffer from these disorders show relative
difficulties or impairments when it comes to emotion regulation?
And so we've been really looking at this question here and really trying to
tease apart what seems to be going on across a wide variety of disorders as a
sort of trans diagnostic theme is that many individuals suffering from emotional
disorders in particular in our lab,
we studied bipolar disorder,
seem to have difficulties in what we call emotion regulation achievement.
So this is the observable emotion regulation performance.
So when left to their own accords,
do they regulate successfully or spontaneously?
And it seems that many individuals do not do it on their own,
but when we bring them into the lab and run them through paradigms such as the
ones I showed you today,
and cue them into which strategies to use and what context to use them,
then it seems that they do indeed have this ability or capacity for successful
emotion regulation performance.
It seems that such individuals with bipolar disorder,
major depression,
social anxiety,
can regulate successfully.
So part of one of the mysteries of psychopathology and emotional disorders that
we're really working on with other emotion regulation researchers such as James
Gross as well as Doug men,
is to tease apart how do we understand this discrepancy between why some
individuals might not regulate successfully on their own,
but yet have the intact capacity or ability to do so.
So here we're really probing this puzzle of the chasm between having the ability
to regulate but not necessarily achieving successfully.
And this is the puzzle we've been looking at in bipolar disorder,
in our work,
but that many other research,
right?
Researchers right now in emotion and psychopathology or trying to understand
more trans diagnostically.
So with that,
I'm going to conclude with our takeaway questions and expert interview.
So for our takeaway questions today,
the first one asks,
how is emotion regulation distinct from related constructs of coping,
mood regulation,
and defense's second,
what are the short and longterm health consequences of reappraisal and
suppression and what about reflective versus ruminative processing?
Finally,
what are the neural basis of emotion regulation discussed today
and now?
I turned to our expert interview as part of the experts in emotion interview
series.
Today we'll be speaking with Dr Kevin Ochsner,
who's a professor of psychology at Columbia University on emotion regulation and
the brain.
Doctor Ochsner received his phd in psychology from Harvard University where he
also received postdoctoral training and social psychology.
He later received additional training in functional neuro imaging at Stanford
University where he subsequently held the position of a research scientist.
He's currently a professor of Psychology at Columbia University and director of
the social cognitive and affective neuroscience laboratory.
His lab studies the psychological and neuro processes involved in emotion,
self regulation,
person perception and their interactions.
He's received various awards for his research and teaching,
including the American Psychological Association's division three new
investigator award.
They cognitive neuroscience societies,
young investigator award,
and the Columbia University's Distinguished Faculty award.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Kevin Ochsner.